Look, I don't see what the big deal is.
So as you might've heard a
lawyer appeared in court as a cat
Let's watch:
- Pardon? I believe you
have a filter turned
on in the video settings.
- Yeah, you think?
I think that's a filter.
- You might want to, uh,
take a look.
- Uh, we're trying to--
Can you hear me, judge?
- I can hear you. I think it's a filter.
- If it is, I don't know how to remove it.
- God, we've all been there
with technical difficulties
that you can't fix.
- I'm prepared to go forward with it.
That's-- I'm here live. I'm not a cat.
- Ha ha! That's gotta be one for the ages.
"I'm here live. I'm not a cat."
Look. The overall lesson here is that
things go wrong in court all the time
and the judge says that this
lawyer handled it with grace
and composure and you just
gotta roll with the punches.
Especially in this pandemic world,
you've got to deal with
things like video conferencing
but the other lesson is
if you're going to have
a video conference with the judge
make sure that A: you're wearing pants
and B: you're not a cat
#NotLegalAdvice
but this is advice: subscribe
or I'll see you in court.